99 of the world doesn't know who the cmo
of anything
is and i want people to get to know more
of the people that i admire whether i
know them well or i don't know them at
all
[Applause]
you got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
[Music]
kenny mitchell joins us as chief
marketing officer for snap
he's their first ever chief marketing
officer and he oversees
everything from consumer and product um
to all the marketing programs
thanks so much for joining us kenny
thanks for having me how can i be bad
and clean up when a-rod was on the count
like i don't even understand this
because kenny you led the nation
everybody who's watching this is real
this man this handsome man who's lost
like 10 pounds visually
i'm impressed i need to talk to you
about that you look in shape during this
time i'm impressed
you've lost some weight i can tell this
man led the nation and assists
the ncaa this is this man led
the nation in assists this is a talented
multi-dimensionally talented man
and that's why you get to do cleanup
because you also
are a world-class athlete and had your
moment to shine tell them
tell the details kenny don't be humble
and then i'll do the full intro
so i love your diversity of going from
mlb hall of famer to an ivy league uh
you know point guard but uh
yeah yeah my senior year in college um i
had the
distinction of leading the nation in
assistance uaa and assists and
i love shout out to your school big
shout out to dartmouth hey
big green um i love to tell the story
that that same year
um the person who led the nation in
scoring
was um none other than tim duncan who
went on to
play 19 years in the nba make 200 and
some odd million dollars five
championships and i became a marketer so
we're like essentially
the single at this this yeah penny what
is your uh
twitter handle for everybody because the
quotes and the screenshots have been
crazy the hashtag
is marketing for the now at k mitch
i hate an early enough adopter to
actually have my nickname
k mitch mitch kenny uh
give everybody one minute on the
incredible hall of fame marketing career
at gatorade
at mcdonald's now snap and anything else
i missed
yeah yeah so i've uh spent the
preponderance in my career actually at
pepsico i was leading
uh marketing or a variety of marketing
roles at gatorade
most notably um where i got
the the the the the the humbling
experience of leading an iconic brand
and working with some of the best
athletes of the world best properties of
the world some of the
sharpest marketing minds of the world um
spent
a little bit of my career as well at
mcdonald's um
spent some time actually at nasa
literally literally a cup of coffee and
on the record shout out to mcdonald's i
like their coffee
not too long because then you had a big
opportunity yeah yeah
um and um you know i got a big
opportunity here
at snap um it's a platform um that i've
been a believer in as an
advertiser um since the very beginning
um
and it started uh during my time at
gatorade gator is such a
consumer driven company that it was not
uncommon for us to be spending time
directly with
our our consumer which are competitive
athletes and they were telling us
back in 2011 and 2012 like
this snap this this is where it's at
this is how i communicate with my
friends we
we actually would get questions from uh
gatorade's version of influencers which
are like athletic trainers nutritionists
dietitians and they're like
is this just for sending nudes like
what's this thing about so
our team had to kind of do a deep dive
to just learn about the platform and
really believed in this notion of this
generation um
kind of transforming the way that they
communicate and communicating visually
as being like the primary format of
doing that
whether it be sending photos or sending
videos
and and it's just like an incredibly
sticky use case and and doing it
um with your friends um was something
that that we we just thought was like
super compelling so
the moment snap started uh allowing
advertising i think it was 2015
we were you know one of probably the
first five or ten to market um
and really learned the platform
incredibly well um saw a tremendous
amount of value in the creativity of
that the ad products
um the reach of the of the consumer they
were a pain in the ass to work with to
be honest um especially we're so young
yeah so young exactly about these big
companies i mean this is what's
happening with tick tock and so it's
going to happen the next four
like when you're so young right you're
trying you're trying to
figure things out so we we were okay i
apologize for interrupting but i'm just
like too anxious for this question
because i'm real curious actually don't
know the answer to this
what's the biggest thing that marketers
and the consumer world doesn't know
about snap
i'd say the one insight that you would
find really interesting that's probably
not well known is that
the the scale of the platform one
example of that
is that in the us snap has more
a larger community of 25 plus
people than twitter has in all of the us
say one more time for people here say it
one more time for the people in the back
because snap is known as a platform for
for for younger folks
we have more people in the us 25 plus
than twitter has in all of the us
all ages so and what is that grounded in
is that grounded in downloads us
active that's not that's doubt that's
grounded in
daily active users versus twitter's
version of the monetizable daily active
user so it's it's it's an
apple comparison so the scale
is actually tremendous and and part of
the reason for that
is that um it's a private platform
snap is a closed platform so um
understanding the user experience only
happens when you're actually using the
platform
which is not true for twitter not true
for instagram not true for facebook
they're all which changes the
viral loop which makes it deeper but
maybe not as wide potentially but to
your point
wider than most think wider than many
think it it it it always
snapchat originals talk to me about that
oh
snapchat originals amazing so it is
essentially
you know us working directly with um
talent with production companies um
and and and basically building out um
original programming
um and uh one of my favorites uh that
that we recently did
um was with the will smith and his
production company uh
the westbrook production group uh
basically thinking about what's
happening right now
um will wanted to find a way to kind of
like inspire and uplift people so he
created this this program will from home
uh where he was literally at home um and
uh and and kind of connecting with his
friends former castmates other talent
just kind of like telling the story of
what it's like to be at home right now
reminiscing on different uh you know uh
activities that they've done together
it uh performed incredibly well for us
to reach like 35 million people
um over the course of the program um and
will
um himself like he he's done
an incredible job in his production
company of understanding how to
build for mobile um he's a
communication beast and communication
beasts win on all platforms
absolutely in the story absolutely so
you know we have um across
originals you know we have them that are
created um not just in the us we have
originals in
uh europe originals in asia um and we
the scale of it is actually really
phenomenal we have somewhere between 50
or 60 different shows that
um reach 10 million uh uh community
members
um during a given season which which is
which is pretty darn uh miraculous
what's been the difference between
marketing a platform because your job is
to market the platform
versus marketing a beverage or a qsr
like what's been the biggest shift
because that is a that is a shift
it is it is i'll tell you that the the
places where i think it's it's been
really really fascinating
um one is um having been an advertiser
and now having accountability both for
the consumer side
as well as the advertiser side i know
the sales pitches that that have come in
when i've been on the other side of the
table
and also what that means in terms of
whether the gaps may be in terms of the
way that that that snap has told its
story
um so that that's been i've um i think
benefited
from having that that perspective in
that point of view but that's also been
wildly different i've never had as many
stakeholders to think about is you're
building out messaging
one from a consumer perspective one from
an advertiser perspective another from
an agency perspective
uh maybe some from a dr um advertiser so
it's it
the the the stakeholders um in trying to
find messaging that is
um that that's addressing the variety of
their needs has been
been pretty different what uh what's on
your mind
through this thing what what's like
what's like what is a top priority
for kenny and snap during this 6
7 8 12 18 week period like what's kind
of
when i say what's on your mind and
putting on your professional app what
kind of comes to the top
you know um
the the thing that's been the biggest
priority for us has been
kind of embracing the responsibility
that we have
um to support our community a
communication
highway yeah it's important it's a
responsibility
well also with uh the the snapchat
generation right so they're they're
they're they're younger folks right so
think of uh
think of younger millennials that's kind
of like the the bread and butter of
who makes our our community and making
sure that we are
um providing them the education
providing them the inspiration
providing them the engagement it it
actually as
as a leadership team and as a company
we've actually felt a
tremendous responsibility
um to help ensure that we're we're
providing the right tools the right
um education the right in information
um to make sure that our community is
well supported
during such like a tricky time is it if
it's a platform that's actually built
for communication
for those that are closest to you like
god damn it could be a more important
time to be communicating with those
closest to you than right now
so that's been a big focus of ours candy
what was the biggest
uh exciting thing in your career from uh
star struck because i think about
gatorade i just this is now i'm just
being selfish now
listen i've been going hard here for two
hours so i'm just going selfish now like
what was the most like i cannot believe
i'm hanging out with d wade would be the
one i'm guessing but there
there's some other crazy stuff snapped
now too mcdonald you've been in some
places my man
so i'm trying to think about like just
on some honest [ __ ]
on some honest human [ __ ] because one of
the fun things about
marketing for the now for me is we want
the world to you know i'm a marketer
that real people know
and the lineup that we're putting over
the next six weeks
is really i want the world to know
marketers
we have an inner industry that knows who
these people
99 of the world doesn't know who the cmo
of anything
is and i want people to get to know more
of the people that i admire whether i
know them well or i don't know them at
all
on this marketing you know now program
so i'm trying to go into kenny the human
for all the people that are following
you now that are going to build a real
relationship with you
give me a true human story where were
you like ho
like calling your like moms or like a
girl or like like you know like your
buddy
like you will not believe the commercial
i'm doing them like give me the true
thing
probably when you met garyvee i get that
but besides that
by the way for the record when he met
garyvee he was like who the [ __ ] is this
dude
so first of all i have actually hung out
with you
in public and have watched scores of
people
request a photo or so like you know
don't don't don't uh
change it don't suggest that where that
you got you're something other than a
celebrity yourself but um
you know i have i've really been
fortunate um i've had a chance to work
with the likes of michael jordan or
serena williams or peyton manning or
usain bolt
um but i i tell you one of my absolute
favorites
is um dwayne dwyane wade
he's uh just a great human being he has
a great team around him and i've
actually had the the the
privilege of traveling with him for some
international programs that we've done
um on the on the gatorade business um
and one that was like
incredibly incredibly eye-opening is um
actually
both of them had this this um dynamic to
it but we went to china
and then we went to australia um over
the course of about a year and a half
and when we went to china and we landed
there were a thousand people
at the airport waiting um
and um i've actually it felt like the
beatles were kind of coming to town
and i personally had never seen anything
like that so like to kind of be wading
through the exit of the airport and
seeing all of the love and adoration and
folks crying like it just
it was it was really insane um and then
we went to australia this was
it was during the nba lockout so i think
it was like 2011
i think was the year and um i remember
him we were doing like this appearance
and some dinners and a few other things
and this cat tweets out like hey i'm
gonna be at this place
doing this thing he tweets it out maybe
like a
half hour or an hour before the actual
appearance happens
and i swear to god there's like 5 000
people outside it's amazing
it was insane so we
you know we he do we do the appearance
and the media stuff inside he walks
outside and it's just
it looks like lollapalooza um and it was
pretty remarkable
kenny you're one of my favorites keep up
the good work i really really appreciate
you thanks for being a part of this
we're gonna definitely ask you to be
back on
well thank you so much for having me
brother love you bro talk to you soon
okay take care bye-bye bye-bye youtube
watcher what's up it's garyvee
first of all thank you so much i hope
you're doing super well during these
times i also want to ask you please
subscribe because my
commitment and exploration of youtube is
about to explode stories polls
more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon
you